Mark Zuckerberg he had an ACL injury but
the way this post looks is just like
someone in the UFC or MMA oh no it's the
same post gusin posted after he went to
the greatest war of all time with Jon
Jones everyone just like oh get you're a
warrior dude get better
bro oh man that's such a shame I was
looking forward to your fight bro he's
all hopefully one day dude gonna delay
the fight for now everyone's like oh man
I was stoked on that bro oh dude I was
dying to see perform man you've been
looking great lately oh man just when
your striking was coming
together oh dude sucked man you just
figur out the UMO PL oh man are you
kidding me just when 2023 couldn't get
any worse now we're can see Zuckerberg
fight get better bro oh man first they
robbed Francis now you're taking
Zuckerberg's fight away from us oh 2024
can't come soon
enough